[Musica]
curiosità complessità e cambiare punto
di vista questi tre concetti chiave
hanno creato un percorso nella mia vita
un percorso che mi hanno portato a fare
ciò di cui mi occupo oggi nella mia
start up sono sempre stato molto curioso
del mondo che mi circonda di come sono
fatte le cose e del perché le persone
fanno le cose nel modo nel quale fanno
sì perché alla fine tutti noi
interagiamo moltissimo col mondo esterno
pensate che prendiamo circa
35.000 decisioni ognuno di noi ogni
giorno e queste poi si traducono in
decine di migliaia di azioni che siano
piccole o grandi ma chissà quante di
queste azioni possono essere fatte
meglio sto parlando di tutto del cibo
che mangiamo di come ci spostiamo te le
attività che facciamo nel nostro tempo
libero ma anche quelle attività che ci
portano via il nostro tempo libero
tipo il lavoro
ed è proprio sul tema del cibo che oggi
vi vorrei raccontare alcune cose
è stata la curiosità a spingermi a
iscrivermi in università quasi dieci
anni fa e ho fatto la
la facoltà di informatica
ho studiato quindi a fondo la cosiddetta
scienza dei computer o almeno è così che
c'è scritto sul mio titolo di studio e
abbiamo quindi a fondo studiato cosa
sono i computer come questi dialogano e
per farli dialogare
ho dovuto imparare a moltissimi
linguaggi di formazione diversi per
poter creare delle istruzioni che
computer potessero quindi leggere capire
e poi effettivamente eseguire ma la cosa
che mi ha incuriosito di più durante
l'università era legata al cibo
ovviamente sì perché mangiavo nella
mensa universitaria magari sia a pranzo
che a cena tutti i giorni abitando non
proprio vicino alla facoltà e com'è che
funzionava immensa
andavi facevi questa fila immensa cioè
levi piatta arriva alla cassa e quindi
sarà un istruzione che dovevi che dovevi
seguire se avevi del credito potevi
effettivamente pagare per il pasto e
andare a consumarlo quindi appoggiarvi
la tessera universitaria su un
apparecchio e questo ti scalava i soldi
e faceva arrivare la conferma di
pagamento che ti permetterà quindi di
finire di finire la transazione e se
tutto funzionava correttamente da questo
sistema molto elaborato potevi uscire
dalla messa senza essere rincorso
e non o non ho mai sta stretto troppi
troppi legami e con i miei compagni
durante durante quegli anni e ho sempre
studiato praticamente da solo in
biblioteca ed è qui che è venuto fuori
la prima volta il detto di marie curie
si in meno curioso della gente è più
curioso delle idee è proprio questa
frase mi questo davvero molto perché mi
ha fatto capire che era proprio la
curiosità che mi spingeva a imparare
sempre di più sui suoi e computer sui
processi e a come migliorare le azioni
di giorno in giorno
era diventata quasi un'ossessione
sì perché anche un'azione piccolissima
come prendere una tessera appoggiarla e
questa ci faceva scaturire un sistema
digitale molto complesso mi ha fatto mi
ha fatto pensare che lo volevo proprio
capire fino in fondo e quindi mi ci sono
messo in biblioteca per cercare di
rielaborarlo da zero da trony faceva
fuori informatica e per qualcosa
quindi dopo diversi mesi ce l'ho fatta a
ricreare delle parti digitali che
potevano un pochino messe insieme
mettere mettere su tutto il sistema
tecnologico che di per sé era molto
all'avanguardia e veniva utilizzato
tutti i giorni da tutto lo staff
universitario dagli studenti anche dai
professori
quindi erano proprio i professori che ci
hanno insegnato come poter far fare ai
computer quello che volevamo noi
ma cos'è che volevamo fare noi come
studenti poi le domande sono andate
avanti cos'è che voglio fare io con icom
più dov'è che posso applicare i concetti
che studio come faccio ad applicarli se
non sono spinto dalla curiosità
se potessimo insegnare alle persone come
essere più curiose se potessimo
insegnare alle persone come fare le
domande sul mondo esterno senza
accettare lo status quo
tutte le nostre vite sono molto molto
complesse all'università poi ci prepara
al mondo lavorativo che di per sé è
piena di questi processi complicatissime
è la mia prima esperienza di lavoro l'ha
avuta proprio qui a persone in una nota
in una nota ditta e sono stato assunto
per fare un punticino nel campo della
digitalizzazione
e
finalmente quindi un'azienda vera con un
problema è vero che aveva bisogno di una
mano da parte mia poi quindi sono stato
sono stato assunto con un compito ben
chiaro di analizzare di processi
aziendali e poi aumentarne l'efficienza
di alcuni quelle immaginate l'arrivo il
primo giorno il primo lunedì di ottobre
piovoso a bressanone
faccio il giro dei colleghi saluto tutte
le persone come sempre non mi ricordo
nemmeno un nome mi siedo quindi alla
scrivania guardo già allora dico ok
mancano ancora 2 2 ore per il pranzo
penso già cosa mangeremo dove anche se
andrà a mangiare poco prima di
mezzogiorno è arrivato quindi il mio
responsabile ad invitarmi a cena sia
cina a pranzo e quindi sono siamo saliti
tutti sulla sulla sua macchina siamo
siamo siamo andati al ristorante più
vicino a seguito poi gruppo se amati ad
un tavolo che era già predisposto per
l'azienda
abbiamo velocemente ordinato e allo
staff e subito dopo
al mio responsabile che ruffian come era
arrivato dal suo vicino piccoli fogli da
firmare
questo ma a pranzo qualcosa da firmare
ma come mai poi sbirciando meglio su
questi fogli ho visto tutti i nomi dei
vari dipendenti della nostra
dell'azienda e poi varie giorni della
settimana con già delle firme sopra
e anche il mio sono salvo e quindi ha
messo una firma su lunedì vicino al suo
nome e poi anche vicino alla sua firma
messo anche un più 1 a che l'ho detto ma
quel più uno sarò mica io in quel modo
ho capito che l'azienda pagava anche per
il pasto per ora totalmente diverso
l'università con una tessera come se
l'azienda avesse un conto aperto che poi
saldava in qualche modo quindi tu passi
dice di far parte
dell'azienda e poeti aggiungono a punto
la carbonara al conto al conto al conto
dell'azienda
tutti i giorni poi il meccanismo sarà
molto molto simile nel senso che
andavamo magari anche ristoranti diversi
però quei fogli erano sempre lì presenti
da firmare e se il mio il suo sapere non
c'era c'era qualcuno che doveva
prendersi la responsabilità di fermare
anche per me ma com'è che funzionava
tutto questo processo
ogni dipendente può andare al ristorante
mangiare quanto vuole emette solo una
firma chi è che ha il permesso di
firmare anche per me poi chi è che paga
poi effettivamente per tutte queste
procede che poi si ritrovano quando è
che vengono pagati tutti questi pasti
come l'azienda a capire se sta pagando
troppo o troppo poco come fa poi
ristorante all'aver tutta questa mole di
formazione a tener traccia
effettivamente anche poi dei pagamenti
tantissime domande che mi stava ponendo
poi io come come il piccolo tirocinante
che era arrivato ho provato a chiedere
ai vari colleghi e questi cosa avranno
mai risposto
abbiamo sempre fatto così
ovviamente
d'altronde il fabbisogno l'abbiamo già
soddisfatto abbiamo già mangiato
bisognava solo mettere una crocetta
nessun altro stress ce ne torniamo tutti
prontamente in ufficio sì perché poi il
nostro cervello e pigra bisogno di
quelle attività di routine parla
velocemente sempre con risparmio
energetico acceso
in questi casi è molto molto importante
analizzare questi sistemi questi tutti
questi processi con una prospettiva
diversa quindi cambiando appunto punto
di divisione
faccio un piccolissimo salto in avanti
di fino alla fine del 2017 dove il nick
che vedete qui davanti da bravo
appassionato di cibo indovinate un po è
diventato un ristoratore sì perché
dopo svariati svariati e vicissitudini
che sono capitate tutto ok
possiamo possiamo farcela a darci a
darci in un nuovo mondo avevo quindi un
team molto giovane molto capace e quando
arrivato il primo giorno quella
dell'apertura avevo già dato tutte le
varie istruzioni da bravo informatico a
tutto lo staff avevamo fatto già tutti
quanti i test nei giorni precedenti
quindi eravamo tutti pronti non poteva
che andare tutto liscio
infatti così è stato per ben quindici o
venti minuti poi un disastro totale
sì la gente dopo che ha mangiato dopo
che ha consumato quindi il proprio pasto
anche voluto pagare quindi si è creata
questa fila inimmaginabile che magari
anche tutti voi potete vedere tutti i
giorni
nell'ora di pranzo quindi se mi mettevo
magari di lato ad osservare questa scena
intorno intorno al al punto cassa potevo
vedere tantissime cose la primissima
sono quelle persone che cercano di
giocare con delle tessere chiamate anche
buoni pasto che poi non è che siano
proprio buffoni queste tessere che
cercavano l'apparecchio giusto e poi
anche la combinazione perfetta per far
uscire fuori uno scontrino c'erano poi
quelle persone che avevano con dei
blocchetti di carta che devono strappare
alla perfezione perché queste avevano un
valore e dovevano quindi consegnarlo al
in cassa c'erano poi le persone che
arrivavano a loro stesso e con delle
istruzioni
da dare quindi in cassa per ricevere la
fattura e rimborsi o anche qualche altro
infine poi saranno quelle povere persone
che volevano solamente a pagare con i
contanti o il bancomat e andare via
velocemente dal ristorante e vi
ricordate poi le crocette di bressanone
dopo offesa ha avuto circa 25 aziende
che mi hanno chiesto a questa forma di
pagamento
ma adesso che finalmente avevo gli
occhiali nuovi dal ristoratore potevo
anche analizzare il tutto da una
prospettiva diversa
e ovviamente anche lì un caos totale
da lì a poco mi sono reso conto che
avrei dovuto riconoscere tutte le facce
dei vari dipendenti
ricordarmeli perché queste dovevano
firmare su dei fogli e dove quindi
sapere se firmavano sui fogli giusti
questo per poi alla fine del mese fare
resoconti contare tutte le varie firme
inviare per email tutte le fatture con i
pagamenti alle aziende ogni mese per
ogni azienda e
per poi tracciare ovviamente anche poi
pagamenti se effettivamente pagavano
da questo punto di vista poi mi son
ritrovato appunto a capire che lo scopo
primario dell'azienda era offrire un
pasto all'intendente e mettere quei
costo nei costi aziendali
ho capito che non c'era un metodo che
potesse far fare all'azienda questa
azione in modo semplice veloce e
finalmente vantaggioso per tutti quindi
dopo svariati mesi di analisi mi sono
ritrovato a creare questa nuova
applicazione che potessero sbrogliare
tutta questa matassa di piccole e grandi
azioni che fosse finalmente etico
vantaggioso per tutti e sostenibile e
racconta una piccola curiosità sul suo
ristorante si trova nella via marie
curie e dei suoli nuovo una citazione
che che vi lascio niente nella vita va
temuto deve essere solamente compreso
ora è tempo di comprendere di più così
possiamo temere di meno
nel futuro non sappiamo bene cosa ci
aspetta quindi non ci possiamo neanche
preparare troppo in anticipo
cerchiamo di capire bene tutte le azioni
che facciamo di giorno in giorno
cerchiamo di scomporle e trovare e
trovare quei piccoli step sui quali
possiamo fare magari degli esperimenti
per migliorarli questo ci permette
magari di applique applicando anche la
curiosità di scatenare poi la creatività
e cercare di fare cose nuove
ogni giorno faccio cose che potrei fare
meglio questo vale per me per voi e per
chiunque altro
tutti abbiamo la stessa opportunità di
rendere le nostre vite più semplici più
facili e più efficienti ovviamente per
risparmiare tempo energia e denaro e
quindi per rendere anche la nostra
comunità molto più molto molto migliori
abbiamo tutti quindi l'opportunità di
fare la differenza quindi facciamo la
grazie
[Applauso]